well i was going to ask you about your
kids but everybody was asked about kids
first how are you
oh i'm okay you're i was so
happy mommy time you're not gonna leave
my house i was so
happy to leave just my room and my other
room
and the kids where are you going mom
where are you going
away away yeah far far away
to burbank to burbank it's been a lot
though
especially when mom's just trapped home
with your kids it's a lot i'm trapped
home with my kids
i hide a lot they find me in the pantry
they find me in my closet they find me
eating and drinking
they find me literally they can find me
and i have quite a big house i'm not
gonna lie
they find you they sense it it's like
the other day i was talking to my
girlfriend and she was we were just i
don't know
just talking i was like behind a chair
in my room like like in like you know
crisscross freaking applesauce
like and i'm like and they're like what
are you doing i'm like i'm in my own
mommy fort
so anyway all my kids do they make forts
oh we made a fort this morning before
we left for school every time the only
reason why that's not because my i threw
a neverland party for my kids so there's
like tps and stuff to the internet
but usually every day is a fort i'm like
can we build something else can we call
it a castle can we call it
you know something a tree house like can
we call it anything else no we have
forts
we have forts upstairs and downstairs we
had a ford in his bed last night
and before i left like the couch had
been taken apart
with every type of pillow sheet they
like just got cushions are all over the
floor
all over the place that's super clean
yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever